[Applaus]
er hat etwas von einem religiösen
disneyland der parka trat neue nicht
unweit von meinem korrespondentenbüro in
moskau
hier war
angegeben
hier bietet die stadt platz für
geistliche gebäude verschiedenste
religionen ein symbol dafür dass heute
in russland religiöse vielfalt herrscht
von der russisch-orthodoxen kirche bis
zum schamanismus das war nicht immer so
in den 70er jahren der kommunistischen
sowjetunion waren religionen verhöhnt
und gläubige wurden unterdrückt
[Musik]
seit dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
sprießen die unterschiedlichsten
religionen die faszinierende vielfalt
interessiert mich darum fliege ich 5000
kilometer nach osten zum baikalsee
dort liegt die insel hohen die wie kaum
ein anderer ort russlands für ihre
spiritualität bekannt ist und nebenbei
wunderschön sein soll die einheimische
fahrer den daria bringt uns zur insel
dadurch eine frage stellen was macht ihn
aus
aaron ist ein heiliger einlage schon ein
ort an dem wünsche in erfüllung gehen
und man in harmonie lebt
es ist tatsächlich so
[Musik]
eine lange religiöse tradition soll es
hier geben habe ich oft von russen
gehört wie wird diese holte gelebt
diese frage will ich nachgehen
regisseurin corinna eisenring begleitet
mich bei den dreharbeiten
1500 menschen wohnen hier die meisten
leben immer noch von fischfang oder vom
tourismus seit jahren wird hier wieder
fleisch humanismus praktiziert
[Musik]
über religion oder geistlichkeit habe
ich schon mehrere fernsehbeiträge
gemacht
einmal sogar über exorzismus das sind
heikle themen über sinn oder unsinn
möchte ich nicht richten
ich will jetzt verraten warum dieser ort
für viele menschen besonders ist
aber wo anfangen frage ich mich
lies doch die inserate meint mein
russischer kameramann tatsächlich
schamanen und geistheiler bieten hier
ihre dienste an
[Musik]
wie seriös das wohl ist ein
vierstündiger ausflug zu den kraft orten
der insel
das wäre doch schon mal was schau mal
wie viele autos gibt
knapp 100 euro kostete ausflugsorte die
kräfte sind nicht gerade billig
doch das scheint mir kein schlechter
einstieg zu sein
über kewill trug bietet den ausflug zu
den kraft orten an
hauptberuflich arbeitet sie als
bibliothekarin
sehen sie wir haben nur eine kleine ecke
zuordnung
das ist eines der bücher davon überall
haben sie noch nichts geschrieben
ich weiß nicht wahllos schreiben sie
doch ich habe einfach nicht genug zeit
ich hatte so viele andere projekte
dieses jahr habe ich es vor
oder wollen sie den schreiben zuerst
über die sagen von wochen man hier die
ältere generation bereit stirbt und es
sehr viele interessante leute gegeben
hat die geschichten erzählen die
tatsächlich so passiert sind
kuba will mir orte zeigen an denen ich
magische energien spüren werde
das ist die straße meiner kindheit
dieses eckhaus das ist das haus in dem
ich aufgewachsen bin
als erstes bringt mich lieber zu einem
baum wo weibliche energien zu spüren
sein
und wenn du hier stehst kommt von unten
wärmen
sogar wenn ein bisschen schnee liegt die
füße werden wer also wissen sie dass das
die weibliche seite ist weil ich viele
leute hierher bringen
und die sagen mir dass hier spüre ich
noch nichts
aber natürlich muss der baum noch eine
starke männliche seite haben
schauen sie wir sind die fähnchen und
das häuschen mitten im wald ein
verstecktes buddhistisches gebildes
häuschen
[Musik]
beim eintreten muss man entweder ein
stäbchen oder eine kerze anzünden und
dann so den raum erleuchten
damit hier keine fremde energie ist
[Musik]
wohin damit
sie können es hier in leben und dann
muss ich genau an dieser stelle inne
halten und sie werden spüren wie die
energie die beine hinein fließt die
energie fließt nach unten und gilt weg
ich bin selber ein ganzes jahr lang her
gekommen
ich musste einige schlechte erinnerungen
loswerden also natürlich nicht jeden tag
aber oft und es gibt noch einen anderen
ort an dem sie etwas spüren werden
spürst du etwas
da müsste schon schneller ich habe
wirklich bewusst ein fehler war die
vollständig zeige die große luftig polit
korrespondenz dass ich die leber große
politik in syrien oder den rücken
erklären was dir jetzt jährigen wir
fühlen mit denen regiert aber es ist
interessant hier
ich glaube selbst wenn ich die energie
spüren würde könnte ich das nicht so
offen sagen vielleicht die menschen sind
unterschiedlich
es kommen hauptsächlich weil sie hilfe
suchen und wissen dass diese orte
existieren und sie bekommen
unterstützung
ich denke was ich hier fühlen nehme ich
für mich persönlich
ich war gerne mit unterwegs
es tut mir sogar ein bisschen leid dass
ich die energien nicht so spüren konnte
wie sie
[Musik]
zufällig findet bei unserem aufenthalt
der insel marathon statt
und wie läuft die bräuchte man stücke
mit energie ich rede mit mir selber und
mit dem biker und was sagte dass ich bis
ans limit gehen soll
ich muss es schaffen er sagt man muss
gutherzig sein und sich von seinen
lastern befreien
dann wird alles gut im leben auf
wiedersehen
um diese typische ohne energie zu spüren
war diese läufe den extra aus moskau her
geflogen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auf der insel gibt es seit dem jahr 2000
auch eine orthodoxe kirche
[Musik]
als katholik fühle ich mich hier auf
vertrautem boden
trotzdem ist es speziell die messe
dauert zwei stunden
die gläubigen kommen und gehen
[Musik]
ich warte bis der gottesdienst zu ende
ist um vater wassili kennenzulernen
[Musik]
erfreut guten tag guten tag
wenn ein kommen sie setzen wir uns doch
jetzt haben wir das schwierigste thema
die spiritualität die spiritualität
lässt sich schwer beschreiben
man kann das nur auf eine primitive art
aber die persönliche religiosität
erfahren und kann ein mensch nicht einem
anderen weitergeben
jeder macht das für sich wenn du an gott
glaubt macht jeder seine eigenen
erfahrung was sie lässt aufgewachsen
werden derzeit als religion verboten und
verfolgt wurden
wie die meisten russen war der damals
erst als die sowjetunion auseinanderfiel
gab es eine art vakuum
es war ein schwebezustand
du hattest das gefühl dass du auf einer
plattform liebst und dann hat man diese
plattform plötzlich entfernt es war
unklar wie du lebst wofür du lebst
wozu dieser zeit habe ich angefangen in
die kirche zu gehen
sie hatten also diese plattform gegen
den glauben ausgetauscht es ist nicht so
dass wir uns ausgetauscht haben
verstehen sie
der mensch muss an etwas glauben als wir
in der sowjetunion lebten glaubten wir
dass wir eine strahlende zukunft
errichten würden alle halbe jahre
verlässt vassili die insel
er besucht die mitglieder seiner
gemeinde die in den entlegenen dörfern
der region leben
eine gute gelegenheit um die
abgelegensten winkel diese region
kennenzulernen
eine kollegin collien hat ihn begleitet
die straßen zu den dörfern sind schlecht
darum fällt vassili mit seinem freund
sascha der einen chip besitzt
es geht mitten durch einen nationalpark
sascha wird diese strecke zum ersten mal
[Musik]
das ziel von priester vassili das dorf
und gurren dort hat das ehepaar chilenin
eigenhändig eine kapelle gebaut
aus trauer um ihre söhne nach vier
stunden fahrt klapperte jeep verdächtig
laut und tatsächlich der tank hängt nur
noch locker am jeep vassili und sascha
improvisieren das muss halten für die
ganze strecke hin und zurück jahres
gewarnt ist ein bisschen unbequem aber
das macht nichts es hat seine vor und
seine nachteile wenn man mit den
menschen kommuniziert ist es einfacher
also die kommunikation mit den behörden
ist einfach aber sie ist keine kleidung
für ein abenteuer das ist halt so eine
sache mit diesem gewand
nach zwei weiteren stunden erreicht was
sie das dorf und uhren
doch die kapelle liegt außerhalb und
dorthin gibt es keine straße mehr
die fahrt geht direkt am ufer entlang
oder besser gesagt über das wasser da
ist gottes hilfe gefragt
ich hab
hallo mama ich bin froh dich zu sehen
wie geht's für anatolien ludmilla zählen
ist priester was seele seit monaten der
erste besucher er bringt ihnen zwei
ikonen mit ikone geklaut das macht nicht
nur das es aber sauber zwei jahre lang
hat das ehepaar an dieser holz kapelle
gebaut
2005 2006 haben sich zwei unserer söhne
das leben genommen
die kapelle ist für sie wir bitten damit
um gnade für ihren suizid
suizid ist der sünde
[Musik]
dass sein besuch bedeutet vor allem dass
ich hier nicht vergessen bin
er kam extra hierher um ehrlich zu sein
ich habe mich ja kaum noch auf den
beinen
ja er ist müde und ausgelaugt und er hat
kein benzin mehr
was sie kann helfen er hat einen
benzinkanister für den alten traktor aus
sowjetischen zeiten was ziel ist
überzeugt dass der glaube und die
spiritualität die beiden alten stärken
für ihr leben in der abgeschiedenheit
werde nicht krank nächstes jahr komme
ich wieder
doch auch die andere seite der religion
war hier spürbar
sie hinterlässt bei den eltern
schuldgefühle wegen des suizids ihrer
söhne
[Musik]
einen den die insel nicht mehr loslässt
ist der französische fotograf nicole
abrechnung
er hat hier insgesamt schon drei jahre
gelebt die insel ist für ihn ein ort von
magischer schönheit
was für ein prachtkerl unser ziel das
kap cowboy traumhaft nicola partner der
nördlichste punkt der insel
halt halt stopp wir fahren weiter ich
gehe lieber die letzten meter das ist
das ende der insel
nein dort ist das ende das ist also das
schönste ort für dich ja jetzt sehr hoch
sehr schön gefällt es dir ja es ist
wunderschön und warum bist du drei jahre
hier geblieben
schau dir und du verstehst es wegen der
schönheit wegen der geist wegen der
schönheit und einige interpretieren es
auch als geister jedem seine
weltanschauung glaubst du denn an die
schamanen die energien die rituale
ich glaube daran
aber ich weiß das ist nicht meine kultur
es ist da ich respektiere das ich habe
vielleicht keinen zugang zu dieser welt
habe ich weiß dass sie existiert dieser
insel zieht außergewöhnliche menschen an
deshalb sind wir hier sagt sie
nicola bern uhr reicht es nicht die
schönheit und die kraft dieses ortes zu
spüren erhält sie immer wieder fest in
seinen bildern die ehe von alkohol macht
über die jahre und jahreszeiten hinweg
[Musik]
an unserem nordkap taucht plötzlich wie
aus dem nichts jemand auf guten tag sind
sie ein einheimischer wie soll ich sagen
fast einheimischer sehr kurz es ist eine
viper gesicht was habe ich das ist wenn
ein mann ein gesicht hat wie eine frau
war es eine schande sich zu rasieren
soll man sich nicht rasieren
sicher soll man sich nicht rasieren
wer hat sich früher rasiert heute zwingt
man alle das erzähle ich meine frau sie
sagt ein bisschen barth geht schon aber
nicht zuviel kosmos je länger die haare
desto besser ist die antenne zu kommen
ja es gibt besondere menschen auf dieser
insel und auch noch ungewöhnlicher autos
die zb nicolas sowjetischen us chip so
einen wollte ich immer schon mal faden
[Musik]
nach vorne und pass auf es ist schwierig
die geschwindigkeit zu regulieren
jetzt in den zweiten gang
das ist cool dieses auto passt mir
irgendwie
[Musik]
am nächsten tag ist ich muss in den
baikalsee
wenn ich länger leben will das zumindest
sagen die einheimischen
sie sprechen vom heiligen meer auch
seine magische kraft die diese ort haben
soll
16 grad kalt soll er sein hat man mir
gesagt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so schön
einige der 100
[Musik]
er ist jeden tag im sommer mit seinem
brett auf dem balkan
für ihn ist es klar dass der baikal
heilig ist
für victor den buddhisten ihn hat meine
kollegin kurdin ein paar wochen zuvor
begleitet
viktor macht ausflüge für touristen zur
insel
dort steht ein buddhistisches heiligtum
eines super eine stunde stehen die
touristen dafür mit dem stand up paddle
auf dem baikalsee der weg nach oben ist
ein schwieriger wenn wir zur stupa gehen
braucht es einen meditativen zusteht
eine innere ruhe wir kontrollieren
unseren atem
die touristen entscheiden selber wie
viel ihnen die exkursion wert ist
viktor will ein erlebnis vermitteln den
baikal spürbar machen
[Musik]
das kann man nicht beschreiben das muss
man einfach fühlen
das ist vollkommener ruhe vollkommene
stille vollkommene zufriedenheit so
verschmilzt mit dem moment du bist ganz
im hier und jetzt
nach einer stunde an over von opel für
den buddhismus hat sich viktor ist als
erwachsene entschieden
auch er ist wenn sie so wird seit als
atheist aufgewachsen und hat sich erst
spät mit der religionen
auseinandergesetzt
vor vier jahren hat viktor seine zelte
in alf hohen aufgeschlagen
im sommer lebte hier zusammen mit
einigen touristen das entspricht ihn
viel mehr als das großstadtleben seiner
kindheit
du siehst hier echte emotionen nicht wie
bei den stadtmenschen die lügen und
betrügen
die leute fangen hier auf euren an sich
zu öffnen
in der stadt sind sie verschlossen und
machen sinnlose sachen sie spielen dort
irgendwelche soziale rollen die ihnen im
moment wichtig sind und hier werden sie
sie selber mit dem brett auf den see
viktor hat seinen kraftort gefunden
geh ins dorf museum hat mir eine
einheimische frau empfohlen da könig
mehr der faden über die eigenartige
dinge die auf diese bilder geschehen
soll
zuerst war ich etwas über die geschichte
der insel
cowen war einst ein kosaken stützpunkt
unter stalin ein gefangenenlager und bis
in die 90er jahre ein fischerei kombinat
dann präsentiert mir cup italiener
nicola die ehemalige museumsdirektor in
ihre lieblingsecke schauen sie hier in
dieser vitrine welche utensilien wir
haben diese gehörten einst einer
schamanin nach ihrem tod wurde die
schamane verbrannt aber ihre sachen
diese hier wurden eingesammelt
das war vor 140 jahren der geist dieser
schamanin sagt uns cup italiener nicola
besucher aber regelmäßig das museum
dafür gebe es zeugen der geister spanien
wurde schon mehrmals gesehen
einmal waren zum beispiel ein paar junge
frauen in der nähe des museums die
früher noch über diese geschichten
lachten sie sahen wie eine frau die auf
der treppe vor dem museum saß plötzlich
aufstand und durch die verriegelte tür
hindurch gehen
es ist tatsächlich so geschehen ich weiß
nicht wie man das erklären können ich
habe solches erlebt obwohl es sich
anhört wie ein märchen
und so erzählt sie mir eine stunde lang
eine geistergeschichte nacht anderen die
heutige direktorin hat eine erklärung
für all diese geschichten
in all den jahren der sowjetmacht wurde
ja praktisch der totale atheismus
gepredigt die menschen haben dann nichts
höheres geglaubt in all diesen jahren
des verbotes haben aber die
glaubensrichtungen wie buddhismus und
schamanismus im innern immer mehr
energie aufgesaugt und angesammelt und
nach dem sowjet ende
wir können die menschen wieder zu
glauben jetzt ist die kraft des
schamanismus viel stärker die ganze
energie die sich in der erde gesammelt
hat die wird jetzt noch viel stärker
zurück gegeben
beeindruckend wie die zwei gebildeten
damen ihre geschichten erzählen
sie tun es so überzeugend dass man ihnen
eigentlich gerne glauben
timo ist ein suchender aus der schweiz
scheint mit seinen 21 jahren schon eine
feine spirituelle ader zu haben
könig
kino kennt sich schon aus auf der insel
und zeigt uns die kraftquelle der
schamanen den schamanen felsen genannt
shaman k
[Musik]
mittlerweile auch ein touristenmagnet
ich habe mich hat der grund halte ich
auch zeitnah wieder im alltag oft nicht
nicht viel zum dieselben als sie zum
weinen
was man halt braucht zur rettung der
wiederum aus mainz
dank 3 3 system ist wie auch in der 16
[Musik]
mit meinen russischkenntnisse helfe ich
timo seiner spirituellen neugier
nachzugehen
die suchen zusammen einen schamanen für
ihn am telefon wirkt er kurz angebunden
und nicht gerade priesterlich
[Musik]
und so fragt ziel von ritual mitmachen
ist einfach so nochmal
bis 11
mit michael guten tag wir sind es
ist doch
siehst du den abstand von dieser linie
zu diesel
der abstand ist ein ganzer finger okay
danke schön aber ich sage dir /
[Musik]
timo will das experiment wagen
kennen sie den schamanen michael
der täter
das sind ehemalige polizist
[Musik]
wow
dadurch europäischen verboten eine halbe
stunde lang stellt der schamane timo
verschiedene fragen zu seinem befinden
und seinem lebenslauf
er findet aber nichts spezifisches dass
er behandeln sollte deshalb macht ihr
eigenes ritual
er singt für timo und will ihm so
energie mit auf den weg geben
timo gibt ihm dafür 20 bringen
[Musik]
die richtung jetzt geht es ist auch das
epos das gesicht so dass du nicht ganz
den muskeln ist normal aber als einer
der letzten die wieder vom tisch
und parallel parallel erschienene
überaus stellen organisiert
internationale kritik aber ich kann dass
das nichts erzählt dann war es mit dem
mittelstand verliert das finde ich in
den exakten ich endlich leben
dann dehnt sich das dann ist wie sophie
dem die fischgräte löst sich also nicht
konkret aber sie standen völlig verloren
und dass ich jetzt auch sie aber hallo
also das ist deshalb ist meditativ und
dennoch diesem schamanen hätte ich meine
seele nicht geöffnet meine kollegin
collien hat die besondere gelegenheit in
ulan ude ein schamane ritual zu filmen
eines das nicht für touristen bestimmt
ist
[Musik]
die schamanin ratner soll in der
gemeinschaft der schamanen einen höheren
rang erreichen dafür muss sie eine
prüfung bestehen
ich bin sehr aufgeregt
ich mache das ritual um mir energie zu
bekommen
es ist schwer zu erklären
für das ritual muss sie ein schaf nach
alter tradition als opfergabe
präparieren
das rad eine schamanin ist entdeckte ihr
spiritueller meister vor sieben jahren
und brachte sie in diese gemeinschaft
später hat sie in ihrem
familienstammbaum bis neun generationen
zurück schamanen gefunden
rund um den baikalsee wird schon seit
der steinzeit schamanismus praktiziert
sagen archäologen noch ein paar details
dann können wir morgen anfangen
je näher die prüfung kommt sie desto
mehr fürchte ich
wir kommen schon fast die tränen
schamanen verehren verschiedene
naturgeister und beschwören ihre ahnen
in den nächsten zwei tagen wird sich
ratner dutzende male in trance versetzen
müssen beim ritual dabei sind ihre
eltern und 20 verwandte und bekannte
und natürlich jede spirituelle schamanen
meister
[Musik]
ratner singt und trommelt sich in trance
sie verwendet keine
bewusstseinsverändernden substanzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
partner ist in trance gefallen
sie ist ein kontakt mit einem ahnen
offenbar mit einem raucher
denn sie ist eigentlich nicht rauchen
[Musik]
am anfang ist es hier schwierig viele
werden müde
man wird auf eine harte probe gestellt
der körper wird schwer da muss man durch
dann geht der körper leicht und
schwerelos und man darf den moment nicht
verpassen
es ist wie ein korridor in dem es hell
wie durchsichtig und leicht aber das
können normale menschen nicht verstehen
bis tief in die nacht hinein
praktizierten ritualen ritual fällt den
tross und kontaktiert einen vorfahren
nach dem anderen
am nächsten morgen der höhepunkt der
prüfung ihre freunde und verwandten
haben vor ort übernachtet sie bleiben
während des rituals immer zusammen bei
ratner
[Musik]
beratener trägt nun eine besserung der
weste und muss noch mal in trance fallen
die west ist extra für sie angefertigt
und wiegt 40 kilogramm fast so viel wie
radler selbst noch nie hat sie eine
solche last bei einem ritual getragen
wird sie die prüfung bestehen
gelingt es nicht aus dem kreis zu fallen
nicht zusammenzubrechen
[Musik]
die prüfung ist bestanden
jetzt kann sie als heilerin noch mehr
bewirken
sie sagt dass sie die last werden des
rituals nicht gespürt habe zur freude
ihres lehrers vor glück hatte ich sogar
die jacke ausgezogen
mir ist so heiß geworden
am abend gibt es ein großes fest
wir freuen uns dieses große fest zu
feiern und das meine ahnen die
opfergaben angenommen hat und natürlich
dass ich die prüfung mit bravour
bestanden habe journalisten kollegen
hatten geschrieben es gebe rund um den
baikalsee keine echten schamanen mehr
ich selber würde mir am ende dieser
reise kein abschließendes urteil
zutrauen den meisten menschen denen ich
auch schon begegnet bin war irgendwie
anzumerken dass diese insel und ihr
glaube ihnen etwas schenkt
[Musik]
ich habe schon vorstellen dass hier bis
zum das tor
[Musik]
beim mal mit offenem haar ca das öl hat
erklärt im moment ihre lyrische medizin
nimmt und ich habe mir überlegt es geht
ja hier über ihre spiritualität und
wofür sogar ritual mittwoch nach
aussagen etwas später oder darüber reden
was suchen und für das mitmachen bei
stück betroffen ist die westend
spiritualität betrifft
[Musik]
in der letzten folge meiner russland
reise will ich ganz hoch hinaus
auf den elbrus im kaukasus mit über
5.600 meter über meer der höchste berg
europas allerdings habe ich vom klettern
und bergsteigen keine ahnung
eine herausforderung auch für meinen
bergführer alexej